this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer this episode is sponsored by
Google play with the help of knighthood
from the studio founded by Steven
Spielberg and the brain genius who
brought you kwibi comes a film that's
aged beautifully as a sequel with
animation that's aged as well as those
Taiwanese news recaps sample Kwai will
Chicano Tresa they also show you were
frankly the one cat Paulo Shrek -
welcome back to what feels like the
Internet's favorite franchise because
the Venn diagram of people with a spare
time to make memes and people born in
the late 90s is a perfect circle and
revisit the film that turned the whole
generation by Shrek shuold
because if the voice of fat bastard
coming out of a green potato wearing a
bra over their shirt wasn't sexy enough
tread - transforms him into the love
child of gaston and john goodman and
people can not handle it
really not looking forward to 10 years
from now and everyone's morning for
Paddington or whatever forget fighting a
dragon and saving a kingdom it's time
for the scariest journey shrek could
possibly take meeting his partner's
racist parents - his type yeah my type
has the Shrek you know in love must team
up with the donkey he's still Epping
Hays on an epic quest to salvage his
clearly doomed marriage who says I want
to be part of this family you did when
you marry me do you think it might be
nice if somebody asked me what I wanted
sure if you want me to pack for you in
an animated sequel about the small
doubts microaggressions and resilience
that build up over time and slowly turn
relationships toxic in the absence of
proper communication
but with Bart's n'stuff gross Shrek will
need all the help he can get to save the
day so he's bringing along an ass and a
porous antonio banderas takes the role
of a swashbuckling latin lover which is
kind of a played out trope at this point
if you think of it oh it's so cute go
ahead and sing with me to loca you
little stereotype you together they'll
take on the fairy godmother a brilliant
and menacing villain who's more nuanced
than the first one sings a cover song
better than the original version with a
third act that had nighties kids more
shook than Avengers endgame inevitable
and I am Mungo the gingerbread man so
enjoy a rare secret that manages to
naturally evolve its characters expand
its universe and develop the theme of
the first film even deeper with plenty
of references that you'll totally get
but some were dated even for 2004 and
some jokes were just repeats from other
Mike Myers movies and sometimes it's
more transport than JK Rowling on a
third butterbeers
but hey times change and Shrek 2 can't
be expected to predict the future or
they definitely would have cut this part
out quick somebody Ford gross story the
shrek is love guru the literal Princess
Diaries v5o psychic horseman how do you
stay oh yes
taw free I'm actually Mary Poppins y'all
only pawn and came apply I'm a
witch and I hover I'm a fairy godmother
and you're the man now Frog Kingdom
Ford's letters the older Crusades wound
playing
wait for Emma's dad fought in a crusade
I get that they have all versions of our
pop culture but our history - who are
they fighting Aladdin this episode is
sponsored by google play yet knighthood
and discover more on Google Play now
shrek is love shrek is life be excellent
to each other - yup I platypus I'm
peeing on the seat give me a raise happy
Anniversary mom and dad